notre collègue Alain Dufour pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste il avait la
parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame première
ministre madame monsieur les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre
l'agriculture bon il n'est pas là mais
je pense que madame Dominique fort va me
répondre sur ce sujet nous avons connu
en 2022 il ne sécheresse importante et
au début de cette année 2023 la question
a été posée à monsieur le Président de
la République dans le cadre du Salon de
l'agriculture il a répondu qu'il fallait
prendre des arrêtés de restriction au
niveau des préfets mais également
proposé dans le cadre d'infrastructures
le développement et la mise en place de
retenue colinéaire c'est dans le sujet
qui vous est proposé aujourd'hui j'avais
déposé une proposition de loi faisant
état de la mise en place de retenue
colinéaire de petites tailles pour des
superficies le moins de 150 000 mètres
cubes cette
expérience elle n'est pas contraire aux
règles de l'écologie et aujourd'hui ma
question monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre pardon c'est de savoir si vous
allez soutenir ce dossier je ne pense
pas que les territoires est attendus le
Salon de l'Agriculture pour vous poser
véritablement cette question qui me
paraît tout à fait pertinente car
effectivement les agriculteurs les
éleveurs les vignerons de ce pays
entendent de votre part une réponse
particulièrement précise et efficace
pour les rassurer définitivement merci
pour vous répondre la parole que madame
Dominique port ministre délégué en
charge des collectivités territoriales
merci
[Musique]
je renouvelle toutes mes excuses pour
l'absence de Christophe Béchu et je
passe brièvement sur les réponses
sur les réponses que j'ai déjà apportées
sur le diagnostic que vous posez
sur ces sécheresses estivales et qui
nécessitent nécessite tout anticipation
que je viens de citer et je viens à la
question des retenues colinaires en fait
pour vous dire qu'il n'y a pas monsieur
le sénateur de dogmatisme il faut les
apprécier au cas par cas chaque projet
qui respectera les critères exigeants
que nous fixons pourra être validé le
stockage hivernal lorsque les expertises
techniques le juge soutenable pour les
milieux lorsqu'il s'inscrit dans un
projet territorial largement concerté et
lorsqu'il participe de meilleurs partage
de la ressource peut-être une solution
les stockages hivernaux font partie du
panel des solutions à mobiliser par
contre ce n'est pas l'unique solution et
sur beaucoup de territoires cette
solution ne sera pas techniquement
possible soyez assurés que nous serons
particulièrement vigilants sur les taux
de remplissage de ces ouvrages dans le
contexte actuel particulièrement tendu
je vous remercie
monsieur Dufour
madame la ministre nous serons vigilants
les agriculteurs seront vigilants dans
la mise en place de ce dispositif car
aujourd'hui il faut être dans l'action
mais non pas dans l'implantation les
Français attendent d'une manière
générale des résultats tangibles et
vérifiables voilà la réalité merci
merci